okay I was super super puppets like been
the talk in the office a quiet place
part two it is here final it here right
first one is such a massive hit so when
you're any sort of like apprehension and
feeling a pressure that wasn't there for
the first time around for the sequel
massive profound anxiety and terror and
all those things and that's why I said I
wasn't gonna do a sequel the studio
actually came to me and asked if I would
do a sequel and I said no I say go find
somebody else to do it because I didn't
think I could ever match how personal a
moment that was for me and a personal
experience making that first one but
also I was so overwhelmed by the
kindness and the respect that the
audience showed that I thought you know
I don't want to deliver them a sequel it
just feels like a cash grab or like you
know the first one did well so this one
we should make another one and then I
had this one idea to make Millie the
lead of the movie and it sort of
unlocked this thing which made the part
to what it is which is part two it's a
continuation of the first movie exactly
yeah and so weirdly as corny as it
sounds I was so aware of making sure
that the audience was respected and
taken care of as much as they took care
of me and that's this is my thank you
note to them the second one is a
thank-you note for the person and I feel
like there could be a follow-up thank
you note like yes forgive me
yeah PS I forgot this yeah I mean I hope
so
the the studio hasn't said so yet but
maybe you can talk now Emily Jude was
originally skeptical about there being a
sequel from what I hear it was a hard
note from Emily oh oh yeah hard now yeah
give me the pitch the pitch was I have
this idea and she was actually really
eloquent and elegant about it she said
you know what how about this why don't
you write the script and I'll just read
it and I'll let you know if I think it's
something to do because I don't know how
we match the first one we all thought
the same thing like all the audience is
like how do you match the first one we
had the same terror and I spent some
time on the script I wrote it and I
handed it to her and she was like I'm so
in I know exactly what you're trying to
do this is not a sequel this is
something bigger than that and I thought
great so she's in and now she's on the
poster
your colleague yeah exactly actor your
lead actor but also know she's the
beginning and of everything creative
that I do so she's the gatekeeper of all
that's good now speaking of your lovely
lady your wife Emily Blunt if the two of
you were in a quiet competition mm-hmm
first who was the Chatty Cathy
I'm the Chatty Cathy are you John yeah
absolutely kay yeah especially if you
get a little white wine and uh oh just
you win a break real quick we break real
quick okay I gotta say I love your
Instagram post with Bryan Baumgarten oh
good yeah have you and Kim I know you're
hanging out yeah no this is the world of
like reunions reboots yeah hello
you're you know cast friends friends is
doing one too I heard that so will there
be a day that we see an office reboot I
hope so I've been yelling it from the
rooftops that I want to do it I can't
wait to do it but I should like an old
school just write the letter yes send a
raven letter
we could also yes and a raven out there
but I'm saying look you you've shown
your chops as a writer as a different oh
yeah no see that's the beauty of it the
the beauty of the offices I would not go
near that that is holy grounds no no no
the writers were the reason why our show
was successful I think the idea of they
were so good at writing these characters
writing these circumstances that if they
can come up with a way to bring us all
back no matter what it is I'll say yes
because I know that they'll come up
something great and I okay so in talking
about the office 15th anniversary of the
office is coming up and leave on March
24th can you give us like a memorable
moment that just really lingers in your
mind phonetic oh I mean there are so
many memorable moments I think that
certainly the audition process for me
was otherworldly it was from another
planet I mean I was a waiter at the time
yeah I mean for me auditioning and
seeing you know doing a scene with rain
for the first time and again I was a
waiter when I got that job so I was
pretty sure I was on the next plane out
of there and
doing scenes with rain and then I very
vividly remember seeing Jenna walk in to
show it for her audition and not even
saying two words to her I knew that she
was gonna get the part and I just said
if I get to audition in this room with
that girl I have a shot and I didn't get
to audition with her and then the last
20 minutes they were like just audition
with this one girl I said oh my god
Jenna Fischer if I get autism with her I
might have a chance she nailed it and
then I just came along Emily says 40
movies PG 40 sorry sorry are they
obsessed with anything that you have now
been turned on to you because your dad
um no I think they pretty much think I'm
an accountant or something when I say
I'm going to work because their mom got
to be Mary Poppins and is now coming up
in Jungle Cruise and they can see all
her movies they're not sure what I do so
I just leave and then I come back that's
all they know
[Music]